white house has incoming everyone run
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
uh
after the initial dollar flew outbreak
on black friday workers at the united
ironworks
a foundry located close to washington dc
decided to set up a camp in the compound
within days the aftermath of the virus
was starting to break down society
these civilians took it upon themselves
to fight back by using the foundry to
produce necessary items
that the people could use to survive
during this time of panic
and chaos unfortunately
it wasn't long before the true sons took
control of the foundry
using it to expand their arsenal of
weaponry out of sight
from the strategic homeland division
however thanks to a man on the inside a
civilian named zak young
or z the division were given a heads up
including information of what to expect
from the true sign officers that were
guarding the ironworks
when i landed to go get the ironworks i
thought i was set
medical dental the works four days later
the green poison made a joke out of my
insurance and took my parents
some of the crew set up a camp in the
foundry and we decided to get the lights
on and reconfigure the machines to make
emergency survival stuff
try to help people you know i guess the
true sons didn't like that
they killed most of us before i even
knew what was happening
apparently they don't think i'm much of
a threat but i've been keeping my eyes
and ears open i swear to god
i'm gonna find a way to make them pay
zee sent through an audio diary of what
he had witnessed from the true sons
but after contacting the division he
managed to escape from his captives
and contact the local division from a
nearby foundry
keeping radio silence he made sure to
keep himself available for contact
so he could assist with the upcoming
operation
heading into the compound agents were
met with strong true sun resistance
led by an officer called lieutenant grey
grey was a former surgeon when things
started going bad
he ended up abandoning his position
taking a number of prescription
medicines with him
and leaving his patients to die under
suspicious circumstances
enlisted with the true sons he was given
training and specially customized
equipment to help him along the way
he was obviously an asset for the true
sons as he was closely watched by three
bodyguards
willing to put their life on the line to
keep him alive
with this and the ironclad technology he
was provided gray would be the first
hurdle that the agents would have to
overcome
in order to find out what the true sons
were using the foundry for
gray used to be a big shot superstar
surgeon somewhere
he stole a whole bunch of drugs and like
a dozen of patients died in weird
circumstances
when the news broke his face was
everywhere he doesn't know that i know
but i know i've seen green poison break
a lot of people
turn them twisted and sour but this girl
was broken years ago
he wasn't what you'd call a natural-born
warrior but he was given a bunch of
training
they even made him a customized mp5 to
make it as hard as possible for him to
[ __ ] up using it
i've heard his bodyguards rip him for it
but never when he's around
three true sons stick to grey like glue
whenever a fight starts
they have these ridiculously big shields
and their top priorities to figure out
the biggest threat to grey's life and
get in the way
his ego is enormous so he loves us
i thought the true suns weren't that
smart but still they managed to take
some division tech
you know that hive nano stuff and
combine it with some of the steel
reserves in the foundry
to make this crazy tough plating in less
than a second
grey can simultaneously armor up and
give himself a dose of combat stims
although i'm pretty sure that's just
spicy stole from the hyenas
after taking down lieutenant grey the
agents made their way through the
foundry with z's guidance
he pointed out a train that had been
kitted out with cannons that was to head
on through the forge
well armoured z suggested that they use
the molten iron to stop it
zee warned the agents of the forge and
instructed them to get to the control
room where they could dump the molten
metal onto the train car and then fire
the water cannons creating a reaction
disabling the car but there was one
thing stopping them from being able to
carry this out
captain fisa visa ran a fire station in
washington dc
what he cares about most in life is
himself
he has no problem stepping on friends
and colleagues in order to reach his
goals
and when the true sons came along he was
all about becoming the super villain
that he'd always dreamed about becoming
using a heavily modified flamethrower
visa throws all caution to the wind
he has a bulletproof suit that hasn't
feeling invulnerable to the destruction
it can cause
not exactly hard to find out about
someone's past when they won't stop
bragging about it
visa ran a fire station in dc blah blah
blah promotion fast track blah blah
although he says it was pure merit that
definitely can't be true
the only thing this guy cares about is
being the biggest toughest loudest
[ __ ] in the room
he clearly gives no [ __ ] about taking
responsibility but loves taking credit
even the true sons brass don't
completely understand how the sand
forged control room works
which is just fine by me means i'm still
useful and less likely to get shot
this one idiot keeps messing with the
panels right outside the door and
shutting down power to the whole place
still at least it makes me look smarter
when i can actually restore the juice
visa bulleted one of the engineers into
bolting an extra fuel tank onto his
flamethrower
and keeps it full of propane he loves
cranking it up and turning the flames
blue
the more he cranks the more dangerous it
looks he's going to blow himself up one
day
hopefully somewhere i can watch
visa constantly flaunts safety protocols
like it makes him an action movie star
or something
i've seen him spray gallons of gas into
the air and then set it on fire just for
shits and giggles
while he was standing right in the
middle of it funny he never does it
without his fireproof suit though
after defeating fiza the division
realized that they needed to find
colonel morizova
if they would put a stop to the truson's
plans
zee directed them towards the main
furnace through the aqueduct
sea said he would make sure that the
door would be unlocked and open for them
to pass through
but the division instructed him to keep
his distance and stay safe
the division managed to take up a few
files on maurizer but they're heavily
redacted
there is not a lot of information saying
who she is or was
but it would appear that she'd been
involved in some high-level politics
[Music]
the agents caught up with z from the
other side of a bulletproof cage
he was frantically trying to open the
door that was blocking the division's
path
he had disregarded the agent's plea to
step back and stay safe
and was about to pay the ultimate price
morizova the officer in charge of the
true sons operation
found him and quickly gunned him down
without a second thought
but not before he'd managed to open the
door to the furnace
although zee managed to get the door
open the agents were met by another true
sons officer
major williams williams comes from
military background
and is extremely loyal to maurizova he
uses a kim launcher that he acquired
from a division agent that he'd killed
and then modified it to use different
types of ammo
another piece of stolen shd tech that he
uses is the riot foam seeker mines
he uses this to pin people down from an
extended range even if out of sight
[Music]
williams and the furnace stand in the
way of the division agents as they make
their way through to the train tracks
agents must gain control of the furnace
to be able to progress
after running the diagnostic process
relieving the furnace lock
and attaining the ideal pressure agents
are met by major williams
who does everything in his power to stop
them from making their way through
tomorrow's over
i avoid williams like the plague most
people do
a lot of true sons seem to have come
from criminal gangs or whatever
but he's got a ton of legit military
experience you could just tell by the
way that he carries himself
he worships mauriziova and does anything
she says
like seriously anything no matter how
[ __ ] up if half of the stories i've
heard are true
he crossed the line so long ago that he
can't even see it anymore
i was never allowed to get near the
furnace i'd need years more training
which obviously isn't gonna happen now
it doesn't help that the guys love to
scare me with horror stories
of how easily it can get out of balance
and how fast it could all melt down if
you went on your toes
one poor dude apparently got melted to
the wall by a blast of super hot steam
right to the wall you do not [ __ ] with
the furnace unless you're deranged
have a death wish or both which is why
i'm not thrilled that williams took an
interest
regular firestarter ammo is already
pretty effective it starts fires
what more do you want well it turns out
williams wasn't satisfied with that
and made a brand new version he used
live targets until he was satisfied that
it burned as hot
and long as he wanted he used my friends
he didn't need to do that but he did
one day he'll get what's coming to him
riot foam is already annoying enough and
williams put it in secret mines so we
can nail people from further away
such a dick
agents make their way through to an area
that shows them the true scale of this
true sun's operation
in front of them was maurizerva's
creation
essentially a train completely covered
in weapons
mortars machine guns and a huge cannon
called the earthshaker
this train would be used to wreak havoc
able to carry large quantities of troops
and was coated in huge thick steel
plates so regular weapons wouldn't make
a dent
using a large autocannon agents managed
to derail the train
and stop it from continuing on its path
to the nation's capital
although now i'm mobile it's still a
threat true sons begin loading shells
into the earthshaker
readying themselves for a mortar attack
it's around this time that colonel
morizova joins the fight
maurizova is an individual who terrifies
everyone around her
she is organized prepared calm and
collected
and legitimately believes that the true
sons will be successful in their mission
to take over the country
she is a powerful speaker and is able to
inspire everyone around her
into believing in their cause
i've seen morizova make one of her
soldiers piss himself
without saying a word she just looked at
him while he tried to explain himself
she's like a robot or something she
never shows emotion
but you know she could destroy you in a
second with her freaky robot strength
people say they saw a loser [ __ ] once
but i don't believe it
i think rumors like that start up
because people want to believe she's
human like the rest of us
but i know what she's done she's not
human
she never talks about her past but her
soldiers love to gossip
the only thing they agree on is that she
broke some kind of all-time record
with her military academy exams years
ago
but after that no one knows where she
went or what she did
she knows a lot about a lot i'm willing
to be she's been all over the world
doing bad [ __ ]
but honestly i'm not even sure i want to
know
she scares me more than anything i've
never even heard her raise her voice
dodging mortars homing rockets air
strikes and countless waves of true sons
the division managed to put a stop to
maurizer's plans eliminating the
powerful officer in the process
this operation was a close call if the
agents had arrived much later they would
have missed the opportunity to use the
foundry itself to take down the train
and it would have been well on its way
into the city
luckily for dc there was a civilian
named zac young on site
who is willing to risk it all in order
to stop them
much like the first raid there isn't
really a huge amount of laws supporting
operation ironhorse
but reports from z were a nice touch and
certainly helped build the scene
apologies if a couple of the bits
weren't 100 accurate i've actually only
played through this raid once
it's extremely difficult to find this
many people to run the raid in my time
zone
i don't think we even have eight people
in new zealand who play the division
on that note i must thank the exalted
clan for pretty much carrying me through
on my first iron horse clear they're an
amazingly patient and chilled group of
people
i'll have a link to their discord in the
description
i hope you've enjoyed this video and
i'll catch in the next one
don't forget to check out my socials
twitter for my whimsical ramblings
instagram for photos of me doing stupid
things with my kids and discord where
the community basically just takes the
piss out of me anyway thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Music]
okay